Democratic presidential candidate who
Leon Castro says crossing the border
without permission should not be a crime
he wants to increase aid to Central
America to help address the migrant
crisis the former Secretary of Housing
and Urban Development is with us as part
of our series the road to 2020 secretary
Castro joins us at the table good
morning to you good morning good to be
with you I don't even know where to
begin you look at those pictures they
are heartbreaking and so disturbing you
hear words like ticking time bomb you
know it almost seems like we are
criminalizing desperation here what
would you do what and what do you think
should be done right now what I think
should be done right now is a lot of
these these folks have relatives who
live in the United States we should
immediately invest the resources to get
them into the hands of family members
who live here or for the children family
members or foster parents people who are
willing to step up as they have been
before and to take care of them to get
them into a loving home I also believe
in the long run that we shouldn't be
detaining families or children like this
that's why I've called for the repeal of
a law that has allowed this Trump
administration to incarcerate these
parents and then separate them from
their little children we need to end
that in the long run we need a 21st
century Marshall Plan for Central
America I mean we had a 144,000 people
that came to the southern border they're
coming because they can't find safety
and opportunity in their home country we
need to partner with on duracell
Salvador Guatemala so that people can
find safety and opportunity at home
instead of having to come to this
country to try and find you're in favor
of decriminalizing border crossings if
you do that how do you still have a
secure border well two things number one
decriminalizing but they're still part
of a court process it's just a civil
process that's the way that we used to
do it from the late 1920s until about
2004 so there's not something radical
this is the way that we used to handle
it secondly we have 654 miles of fencing
we have thousands of border personnel we
have planes we have helicopters we have
guns we have security cameras we have
boats we have a border that is is being
secured and we can maintain security but
what we ought to do is use compassion
and sense and not cruelty and what you
see there those images that you see
that's not who we should be that is
evidence of a dark heart of cruelty of
this administration that I think is
unbecoming of this country the you said
earlier that you think the cruelty is
almost on purpose what's the point of
that quilty then well it's clear that
this president has used migrants as a
kind of political pinata to get elected
that's what he did from the moment that
he walked down that escalator came down
the escalator in 2015 he did it
throughout the campaign in 2016 he
continues to do it on their backs he
thinks he's gonna win another narrow
electoral college victory but at the
same time this is not who we are as
Americans or should be and he's betting
on that cruelty I'm betting on the idea
that people know there's a more
effective way to do this and I'm betting
on compassion instead of cruelty what do
you make of the fourth of July plans in
Washington this year when I saw that the
National Park Service is dedicating two
and a half million dollars out of lot of
money that they're supposed to spend on
other things on taking care of the parks
for things like the tanks that we saw
that are gonna roll down or be on the
National Mall you know it's so
interesting in the Obama administration
we reduced veteran homelessness by 47
percent between 2010 and 2016 that's
what we were focused on taking care of
our veterans who had served this country
it started to go up in the Trump
administration and instead of addressing
something like veteran homelessness he's
spending it on boosting his ego with a
parade that's fundamentally about him
and then getting tickets into the hands
of wealthy donors for the Republican
Party what a waste of money I want to
ask you quickly about an issue that came
up in the debates about private health
insurance when asked whether they
eliminate it you are one of the
candidates who did not raise your hand
do you think the party risks losing key
voters by bringing up eliminating
private health insurance no I mean I
think that there's there's support both
ways for me if you look at whether it's
the Canadian system or some of the
European systems that have universal
health care and where the the government
what government-run health care
is is the primary means of delivering
health care they still have the ability
to have a supplemental private health
insurance plan so I believe that if
somebody has a supplemental private
health insurance plan that that's fine
but the default should be Medicare
secretary Castro but before we go can we
just say you had a bit of an ego boost
with the debate the other day your
number took a little tick up yeah
there's a poll out today yeah yeah this
morning which is the for the first poll
that shows me getting up into that
higher tier of candidates and so we got
a lot of momentum and we're gonna build
on it you know your competition is as
well as any of us in fact better who do
you think you could work with in an
administration or a split ticket or what
of your competitors of the other
candidates of 2020 and I want names
secretary I want names yes I've had a
chance yeah there's a camaraderie
question so I've had a chance to talk
with a number of them had good
conversations with Elizabeth Warren with
Cory Booker Carla Harris people always
ask about the VP and I say I'm just
trying to actually get the nomination
right now and make yours on that yeah
those are three names thank you
secretary Castro thank you